that is very pretty we're going to put
some sodium into liquid ammonium so what
happens is that the sodium reacts it
releases an electron become sodium
single + and those electrons get
solvated by the ammonium it's a really
unusual thing in chemistry to have just
electrons themselves being solvated here
we have a Jewess it's just like you put
a thermos flask or something you put you
cold drink or hot tea and in it we've
got some solid co2 Kardos and acetone so
that brings the whole temperature down
to about minus 78 and we need to do that
because ammonia boils at minus 33
degrees so we've got ammonia in this
cylinder over here we've just condensed
some of that into this sealed tube which
currently is not sealed but we're using
this because it's got nice thick glass
so as we put the sodium in you'll see
that blue color forming it loves you
heat up because there's some salvation
going on some heat of salvation so we'll
have to dunk it back into the cold bath
just stop all the ammonia from boiling
off so we've got cut some sodium up we
had a big lump of sodium cut some bits
off that and we're going to put smaller
chunks in this is going to go in there
and hopefully it will not be too
vigorous reaction there you go so you
can see that blue color already forming
as the sodium reacts with the
with liquid ammonia
that's going a nice deep blue color I'll
just dip that back in to keep it cold
Wow like ink yeah yeah so the sodium
wants to lose an electron must be sodium
plus it's much happier being sodium plus
so it's releasing those electrons into
the ammonia solution they're being so
vated which is where I get this intense
blue color
it's that solvation complex so if we get
the concentration of electrons high
enough then it changes color again it
goes to a sort of metallic color so in
each adding a reasonable amount of
sodium to get that to happen what will
happen is that the ammonia with all the
electrons in that's slightly more dense
and so that separates out from just
ammonia you'll get two layers and you'll
get a sort of metallic icky bronze sort
of coloured layer put some more sodium
in there you can hear it fizzing as it
reacts so we've got a really really
intense blue color now almost looks
black that's but one in there the
thought I'll be enough but you never
know so we're already starting to see
some of that bronze the surface
okay so we've added some more sodium
I've gone from very deep blue to almost
black we're starting to see some signs
of this metallic sheen
but we don't really want to put too much
of that on because otherwise all born
all wrong
so we're trying to get the molarity of
the electrons in solution to a certain
point where we get a separation of the
layers we get the solvation electrons or
look some italic II and the rest of it
we'll look I'll see what it looks like
I see air now it's you
while we're reacting the sodium with the
isopropanol so now we're making sodium
isopropoxide so all the electrons will
be reacting away again we'll get
hydrogen gas in there a bit more
so getting this little gray sodium
isopropoxide ugly old nice solution yeah
looks like a experiment gone wrong in
alignment it's not it's doing what it
should do is making everything safe so
we can dispose of it the last remnants
of this metallic solution here oh yeah
but still looks yep lot of electrons in
there we put quite a lot sodium in there
these electrons that are in there
they're free are they they just like
room their solvated so the ammonia there
are many ammonia's around the electrons
and at certain concentration the
electrons reflect the light and you can
see it is this or metallic solution the
electrons are getting less concentrated
in this bit down here more concentrated
up here where they're reacting this nice
flow going on put that down before it
goes all over my cloths
it's flat it's flowing up yeah the
liquid metal then like mercury it's not
silvery colored it's gold colored or
bronze colored
so what's the what's go what's the blue
and look up capri there's different
concentrations of electrons in solution
that's the only difference look at
that's the separation we were looking at
whoa that's right so the Goldy coloured
bit has more electrons and the blue less
and you can see on the bottom is just
going clear where the isopropanol is
reacted
it's not funny quenching of it actually
is more interesting than the yeah often
the case going on at the top there with
that crusty sort of powdery nose this
white stuff up here it could be see the
sodium amide or sodium isopropoxide it's
also white side so that is really quite
pretty nice yeah thanks clarion yes the
way that is very pretty real chance of
spreading to other people and to their
conversations and that's just there's
just no good and that would make me feel
very guilty
so these months that you famously spend
researching videos yes are you wanting
them to be really correct because you
feel this responsibility to make the
world a better place or because you fear
hateful comments and criticism which is
a I I would say